what's up everybody Chris Pratt here
they've given me a camera and a list of
rules all of which I'm gonna ignore
to be reunited with this Guardians
family for volume three it's really
fantastic we're genuine fans so there's
something really sweet about geeking out
on set
[Music]
[Applause]
Ting the Guardians is about humor it's
about action it's about Cosmic
Adventures
Drax sit up that's what it's here for
tracks it's called a sofa it's not bad
what find it hard to believe it doesn't
have multiple purposes
but it's really about this found family
don't forget where we came from this is
a rocket origin story we are learning
more and more about what rocket has been
through
we're always searching for a family
until we found each other
let's give the Galaxy something to
remember us by
it's so beautiful
everything is in the details it's
imagination Music Beautiful imagery it's
really a fantastic story from the brain
of a Mad genius James Gunn
everything that drives it is that
emotional Center of all of these
characters who are all Outsiders we have
been running our whole lives Pete I'm
done running
[Music]
hello everybody I'm so proud of what
we've accomplished I want you all to
know that I'm grateful to find beside my
friends
it's another rock opera it's really
fantastic and it wraps it up in a way
that really only James could are you
ready
for One Last Ride
will all fly away together into the
forever
and beautiful sky
[Music]
thank God I don't operate the camera for
this movie because if I did it would
look terrible
[Music]